[Music]
I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one you know it's amazing there's so
many different issues that's going on
right now in the world in America
whether it's uh Israel Palestine whether
it's Ukraine Russia whether it's lgbtq
and schools whether it's there's so many
different things we can talk about I am
interested in people that want to
educate and tell the history and
encourage people to be self-reliant
self-help stand up for yourself
responsibility do something about it
messages like that that challenges you
by the way those are the messages that
are by far the most annoying messages
that's why my dad told me I never liked
it that's why my drill sergeant told me
in the Army I never liked it that's why
my boss would tell me to say get off
your tail have a better attitude be
energized be excited you can do
something about it it was so annoying
where you want to say but you don't
understand the life I live you don't
understand what my parents parents went
through a divorce you don't understand
what it is to be born in Iran and live
in a refugee camp you stop feeling sorry
for yourself and do something about your
life that message is absolutely a
message we need more of today and our
guest today has the moral authority to
give that message I watched him on Dr
Phil and I just got to tell you I'm
getting the chills right now just
thinking about the message he gave I got
so excited about it I said I have to
meet this man and I talked to Robert I
said Robert let's figure out a way if we
can get this uh gentleman to come down
here and share US History because he'll
say it himself and it's not hard to to
find he wasn't born in the'80s not in
the 70s not in the 60s not in the 50s my
dad's 1942 he wasn't even born the 40
40s he's born 1937 April 8th my dad's
April 10th I'm I like respect a lot of
April babies and this man's seen it he's
lived it I believe he was a you know in
a in a good-sized family when his father
died when he was I want to say 9 years
old and a lot of different experiences
so you know to properly introduce Mr
Woodson is a civil rights activist
Community Development leader author and
founder of the president wood Woodson
Center a nonprofit research and
demonstration organization that supports
neighborhood-based initiatives to
revitalize low Community low-income
communities the Woodson Cent has
supported a wide range of initiatives to
revitalize low-income communities to
give you stats on what they've done his
program has helped more than 2,600
Community groups in 39 states and and
these initiatives have included after
school programs job training programs
and programs to reduce crime and
violence Woodsen hat has also been a
vocal critic of government programs that
he believes perpetuate uh poverty he's
the author of several books a recent one
called red white and black rescuing
American history from revisionists and
race Hustlers which we will put in the
description below and in uh chat for you
to be able to order with that being said
Mr Bob Woodson it's a pleasure to have
you on the podcast well thanks for
inviting me yeah when I watch you watch
you talk and you give the message it it
fires me up and by the way I want the
audience to hear this for us to mentally
get into the right message so the
podcast Bob can you play this clip Rob
from here's uh Mr Bob Woodson on Dr Phil
there's an exchange of ideas there's
some discourse taking place and then you
say this and this goes absolutely viral
all over social media go ahead and play
it Rob you dissect that you will find
there were about 3,000 700 free blacks
who own 12,000 slaves black slaves the
question is do the descendence of those
free blacks who own black slave do they
pay blacks really uh benefited more the
first hundred years after slavery we
have in the last 50 years I was born in
1937 during the
Depression everyone in my small
lowincome black
community 98% of the households had a
man and a woman raised in children
elderly people could walk safely in that
Community without fear of being
assaulted by their grandchildren never
heard a gunfire during that time never
heard of a child being uh shot to death
in the crib but there 50 children today
who have been shot and killed in our
cities if you you talk about remedies
we've got to look Beyond of saying that
that every solution has to have a a a
winner and a loser that blacks can only
benefit if whites lose we have to be
defined more than just victims of
Oppression so you have to realize this
is a very difficult message to give
today it's not a popular message by
Academia it's not a popular message by
mainstream media it's not a popular
message in a lot of different places and
some may even say I've never heard of Mr
Bob Woodson so for those who have not
heard your story obviously I have and
many people have but those who haven't
if you don't mind
you can go all the way back from being a
kid growing up wherever you grew up
experiences that led you to believe in
self help self-reliance responsibility
if you don't mind walking through that
that would be wonderful no well thanks
uh no as you said I was born in
1937 um right in the end of the
depression um loan family youngest of
five children uh my dad was a veteran of
the first world war and was injured and
really died died as a result of delayed
trauma that he experienced but he died
when I was nine even my mother with a
fifth grade education and uh five
children to raise uh in but in this
community it was uh lowincome segregated
Community all blue collar people but we
had a loving community and there were
men who stepped up and became surrogate
fathers uh to me all of the children
could read uh um the segregated schools
at the third grade plays were held at
night so parents could attend and on a
back table there were lunch pales that's
the level of community that we had in
the midst of segregation uh in the
north um and and so it meant that
growing up in a situation where you've
got challenges within your family you
have to rely upon your community and I
did there were Civic organizations the
Elks I can go on a list of organizations
when Father and Son Banquets um a man
would come by from the from the lodge to
pick me up and take me to a banquet uh
and so there was strong uh community at
that time um and my friends were um uh
were more I understand
gangs because when you have a family
like that you must rely on your peers uh
and I did and fortunately I was blessed
with having the kind of values from that
Community I selected good friends one of
them the public may know um he was
Gordon on Sesame Street Matt Robinson
wow he was the first black on Sesame
Street oh wow that's his uh his I he
died a few years ago and I presided at
his funeral in Hollywood but his
daughter is Holley Robinson the actress
wow married to Rodney Peak he was the
only one who know but the the point is
that we we had a really safe a secure
Community never never heard of gun fired
not not all of us were poor we had uh
holes in our shoes but everyone did you
just you just got a good piece of
cardboard and cut it out put it
in um and but as a result of that um I I
grew up like that my my friends were a
year older and so I they graduated from
high school and I quit school at 17
because you can't grow up in a
neighborhood unaffiliated so I went into
the military at a even at that time you
couldn't grow unaffiliated unaffiliated
what were the gangs back then it wasn't
really uh tough gangs or you you could
walk out late at night without fear but
you still there were problems there were
challenges and and so I went into the
military
1954 um to the air force uh where I
confronted segregation in Mississippi
but the Air Force was a place that put
this all together uh and so I learned
camaraderie I heard my first Southern an
accent when I was 17 I thought blacks
were a majority until I got to basic
training and and my uh Squadron was 80
uh and it was only eight blacks I said
wow what's going on in this country but
but it was a great experience the and I
got out and and but you know what my
mother did was Radical that helped me
understand when I was came home after a
year and I um came from Florida I was at
the K I was on the space
program and I spent my money that I was
going to use to go home my and I went to
my mother said I need caret at home she
said you need to get back the best way
you can it took me 3 Days To hitake A
th000 miles wow but you know I was angry
at her for two months but from that day
forward I said whenever I go anywhere I
have to have the means to return and the
develop veloped a very strong sense of
knowing that my destiny is determined by
what I do for me under those
circumstances now was mom like that with
everybody all five of you yep and what
did the other four end up doing they
were blue collar people they're all all
lived successful lives had families
raised children um but they respond we
were in a community but but the value
the pervasive values in this commun had
nothing to do with race you know I keep
telling people when whites were at their
worst we were at our
best and and so but I became active in
the Civil Rights Movement but I um I
challenged the Civil Rights Movement I
left the movement on the issue of forth
busting for integration I did not
believe I believe the opposite of
segregation was desegregation not
integration so and but also we LED
demonstrations for um against uh a
pharmaceutical company when they
desegregated they hired nine black PhD
chemist and we asked these professionals
to join us they refused and I realized
that it wasn't enough to have the doors
of opportunity open that you have to
have the means to walk through that door
and the Civil Rights Movement was not
interested in that and so I left the
Civil Rights Movement uh following the
death of Dr King and began to work on
behalf of all lowincome people
regardless of their race or ethnicity
and I have and that's the biggest
challenge we face today it is not a race
problem in America when you say that a
lot of people would disagree with you
and they would say how could you say
that you know maybe you you you're
you're maybe it wasn't back then but you
don't know the America today you know
you don't know what's going on with the
challenges they're facing and the level
of racism they're experiencing today in
the marketplace because maybe you are
disconnected kind of like how you were
when you thought everybody was black
until you joined the army and you
realized that your unit only eight were
black what do you say to the people that
literally 100% disagree with you and
they say there is racism today it is a
challengeing time today what do you say
to them I say look at the evidence look
at the evidence you know a lot of people
are like the farmer that came to the the
creek where it was like coming it was 3
feet high and moving at about 20 M an
hour and he forced the mule in and they
were swept down the creek a year later
he CES to the same Crossing this time
it's only 6 Ines the we refus uses to go
in because the mule had good memory but
poor
judgment conditions were not like they
were back in segregation when I was
locked up twice in Mississippi the
conditions have changed but many of us
have but again look at the evidence when
whites were at their worst we were at
our best as I said uh in 1930 to
1940 when segregation and racism was
enshrined in law blacks had the highest
marriage rate of any grp group in
society elderly people could walk safely
in those communities without fear wow of
being assaulted by their grandchildren
so let's look at the
evidence uh we when we refus access to
hotels we built our own hotels financed
by our own uh means the wahaj in Atlanta
the Carver and calber hotel in in in
Florida the St Charles in in Chicago the
St Teresa in New York I could go on and
on when we were denied access to
colleges we built our
own um and and in fact our small
business formation rate was higher than
than whites in the 20s and that really
determines any group's participation in
the economy it is not what government
does for you or what white people do in
fact I think those who continue to push
this race agenda are
eurocentric they assume that the destiny
of blacks is determined by what white
people do that has never been the
case uh we closed the education Gap in
the South between 1920 and 1940 how do
we do it Julius rosenwall the CEO of
Sears came together with Booker
Washington and he put up $4 million the
black community match it with 4.8
million we built 5,000 schools to teach
ex-slaves how to read and write and as a
consequence of that study that the in
between 1920 1940 the education Gap in
the South between whites and blacks was
three years eighth grade for whites
fifth grade for blacks within 20 years
that Gap closed within six months there
were four five high schools at the turn
of the century in New York Baltimore
Washington Atlanta and New Orleans they
had used textbooks overcrowded
classrooms half the budgets of white
schools but but every one of those
schools out tested every white school in
those
cities if we were able to close the
education gap between 1920 and
1940 through self-determination and hard
work if we were able to
outest uh White schools in those
cities then the question is in those
same schools today in Baltimore for
instance where they're run by blacks not
a single student student could read at
grade level or perform at grade
level and so how can you say that it is
racism that is the cause of the present
day
challenges when under under under
segregation we achieved one other an
example we gave from our on our studies
in
1943 blacks were prohibited from being
naval officers
Ela Roosevelt was persuaded her husband
to train him so they selected 16 black
uh college educated men for training the
Naval Academy not Academy Naval Training
Center the Navy says aha we're going to
give these black Cadets in eight weeks
but we give white Cadets in 16 so they
wash out M when these brothers found out
what the deal was they covered the
windows in their barracks and stayed up
all night and studied when they were
tested they scored in the 90th
percentile wow so then they said well
they cheated so they tested them
individually they scored in a 93rd
percentile 13 of them eventually
unbelievable 13 of them eventually
became naval officers they called him
the golden 13 you can look go this that
test the test scores today has never
been uh
bettered so so again I respond to people
with
evidence the incarceration rights of of
rates of blacks from the turn of the
century up to the 60s was under
25% incarceration was under 25
25% where we at today it shot up to to
to uh I think I think it was like 90,000
blacks were in jail
1960 that went up this 900,000 ten wow
over the next uh 30 years why do you
think that is what happened what changed
in the 19 again in our studies red white
and black we looked at the um we looked
at the uh the experiences we looked at
six major plantations to find out what
the state of marriage was of EX of
slaves 75% of those slaves had a man a
woman raising
children the nuclear family continued to
prosper in the face of segregation for
100 years but all of that changed in the
60s with the poverty programs Lyndon
Johnson yes Johnson came in and and and
what happened was the the social
scientists who were pushing socialism on
America cloud and Piven at at Colombia
said if you disconnect work from
income then school dropout rates will
increase drug addiction all of those
things and the and and so what the
government did was offer welfare as an
alternative to a man in the house we
relaxed the rules we we we we we
separated work from income and as a
consequence uh that was supported by the
Black Power movement also the women's
movement was
anti-man and so you had a combination of
social policy but policy alone wouldn't
have done it the federal
government uh enticed
welfare the blacks to Co on welfare
blacks welfare used to be stigmatized in
the black
community but the federal government
began to interpret it as
reparations and from so as
entitlements they withdrew any
requirement that you you should tell the
paternity of the of of the father
paternity in in in cases of pregnancy
all of these so that more blacks were
were came into the welfare system in the
first five years of the
70s uh that then Millions flooded into
the system at a time when the
unemployment rate was under
4% so it is a combination of social
policies plus the Civil Rights Movement
morphed into a race grievance industry
and many of those civil rights leaders
became Mayors and elected to public
office where 70 and we spent $22
trillion during that period on programs
to Aid the poor where 70 cents of every
dollar went not to the poor but those
who serve the poor what percentage of it
70% 70% of the 22 trillion went to the
people that sered the PO poor they asked
which problems are are fundable not
which problems are solvable so in other
words a friend of mine describ it this
way he's having a cabin built in
Wisconsin his electrician is a drunk and
the carpenter is an alcoh has one
leg his value their value to him is
their skill but if he was a
disabilities
director their value to him would only
be the
disability so we have a situation where
we have really created a commodity out
of
poverty and and by the way when you're
saying these numbers what it makes me
think about is this so
why if you go back 1940s you know the uh
uh only 4% of kids that were born in
America are to a single mother okay that
increased from 4% to 40% okay and the
numbers are staggering where it's at
today
specifically 70% in blacks and different
in you know different
communities why do you think this
happened and you know I if you were to
say well here's how we can get get away
from this this is how to fix it so one
why did it happen how do we get here two
how would you fix it well first of all
we we got here because we we had the
social policy that that incentivized
single parents in other words I I had a
young uh couple she said that um my my
husband I'm a j my husband's a janitor
and I'm a secretary and he lost his job
she said I applied for welfare as a
married couple and they refused me
but she said if if but if I was a single
mother then I can get help and so so you
really provide a disincentive for
marriage and you wonder why you get it
you get more of what you reward unless
of what you punish and so over the over
those decades we have we have punished
single parent households the more you
work the more your in other words the
more you work
uh the the war perverse incentiv for you
if I work and get a raise I'm going to
get uh lose child
care so um so that's that's that's why
we have a an A system that
disincentivizes
work and and and and marriage and you
you had certain politicians that would
use that but they would spin it for
votes oh we're paying we're paying poor
women to have kids you would hear that
in political speeches I'm going to
change that we're paying poor women to
have kids and it made it sound like that
that the poor women were the problem
right that they're just taking advantage
of it you know when you go back and what
you're talking about I think it's
important to to look at Lyon Johnson and
remember when they were saying the Great
Society it was great society for who
because the government was very very our
government has been actually pretty bad
at getting Americans to move and change
they're pretty good at getting us upset
but they really don't get Americans if
you look at history to really move and
change our government has never really
LED but our government has been
excellent at being a catalyst of where
they want us to go and to let us go and
to your point they create this Catalyst
you know what do they say with explosive
the explosive isn't the problem it's the
Catalyst you put in the explosive so
always keep those guys separate
government has been the Catalyst and
what you're talking about is what they
did is they knew what they were doing
and they knew that these things would be
a catalyst of changing Behavior because
they couldn't stand at the pulpit of
government and demand that you change
but they could put things out there and
sit back and watch and that's what
you're saying right but I also uh
realize that that the the that that
you've you you the question is what are
solutions if you say that 70% of those
families are raising children that are
not are dropping out of school it means
30% are not what we do at the Woodson
Center is we go into low communities and
we go into the homes of the 30% to find
out what is going on in those households
these are people are raising children
that are not dropping out of school
they're not in jail they're not on drugs
they are confronted with the same
economic
circumstances but and so the question is
what is it that that's going on there
that's success CL success so that's why
I fall conservatives also is that they
have been
preoccupied when it comes to poverty but
only studying failure so Charles Murray
and some of the others all they do is
talk about okay if people on welfare
let's provide perver let's take the way
to perverse incentives I'm for work
requirements I'm for drug testing but
you can't stop there what we do at the
Woodson Center is that we go look for
capacity we and so many of the people in
the
30% uh we need to hold them up and take
what works for the 30 % and expand it to
the 70% and that's what we do but it's a
moral and spiritual crisis and it is not
an economic and social crisis but but
policy be the left or right of Center
takes very little into account of
restoration moral Redemption Faith uh
and many of our groups who have been
able to survive under the worst of
mistak is because of their faith but but
but the whole issue of faith is not even
a factor in in supporting people's
restoration uh we have gone into some of
the the most drug infested crimer ridden
neighborhoods where there were 53 gang
murders in the five square block area in
two years 25 years ago DC we supported
five young men who were ex offenders who
came to Christ and became
redeemed but they had the moral
Authority and the social Trust of their
peers and so they went into these these
neighborhoods and brought the leadership
of these kids who were doing constru
destructive things and they became
agents of remoralization of these kids
and it's just like the in in the
marketplace only 3% of the people are
entrepreneurs they generate 70% of the
jobs right well well a lot of these
these organizations are social
entrepreneurs it only takes a small
number of them if you can change them
and make them an agents of a restoration
they can change a whole community and we
found that to be the case where in this
community called bending Terrace by just
going in and reaching 16 kids who were
leading uh predators and changing their
values and their attitudes how do you do
that by witnessing to them you take some
man who has been in jail who has been
faced all the challenges from an abuse
household and saying you are not def by
the worst of what you you were you and
I'm a witness that you don't have to
stay there because you've been there
where did this self-help mindset come to
you where did this self-help mindset
come by looking at what we did in the
past in other words what I've done by
learning if if if our people could in a
face of slavery and discrimination build
families uh and and restore their
communities then all we've got to do is
go back and take the values that served
the the interests of our people then and
apply them today in other words taking
old values and apply them to new
realities with the consequence that you
can but a witness is more powerful than
an advocate and experience will always
Prevail against an argument I debated
this with Hawk Newman uh it's on YouTube
for one
hour uh I didn't argue with him I
confronted his Pro his proposition with
my facts and saying if we were able to
learn and close the education Gap under
segregation why can't we do it
today you know and so so that's what you
have but but it's we don't realize the
power of somebody coming to a a young
man or young woman who has been uh
engaged in antisocial
Behavior Supply them with a mentor that
that witnesses to them to say why don't
you use your your your skill and talents
to rebuild the community and not tear it
down I want I want to play this clip to
you did you ever have any interactions
with MLK or Malcolm X yes I did I uh met
Dr King in fact I he came to I lived I
did my civil rights work in Westchester
Pennsylvania that's the home of bared
Rustin and so Rustin would bring Dr King
to town to bring the media then they
would focus on our local issues and you
met them face to face yeah and what was
it like when you met King just a
wonderful experience he was the one who
said that uh we must reach down into the
deep dark regions of our soul and sign
and ink our own Emancipation
Proclamation Malcolm X said the same
thing he said our destiny is never
determined by what an oppressor does or
does not do he said I our destiny is
determined by what we do Fredick Douglas
said the same
thing but but that but those messages
are being spun today they're not you
know these are two two Heroes to two
different sects of the African-American
Community sometimes and some the same
but it's it's a it's it's it's spun in a
different way where it's still coming
more from the victimhood mentality it's
coming more from the entitled mentality
not coming from the fact that we can
stand up and do something about it I
want to play this clip to you by Malcolm
X it's just audio the the video isn't
out there it's just purely audio and I
want to get your thoughts on this go
ahead and play this the white liberal
differs from the white conservative only
in one way the liberal is more deceitful
more hypocritical than the
conservative both want power but the
white liberal is the one who has
perfected the art of posing as the
negro's friend and benefactor and by
winning the friendship and support of
the Negro the white liberal is able to
use the Negro as a pawn or a weapon in
this political football game that is
constantly raging between the white
liberals and the white
conservatives the American Negro is
nothing but a political football and the
white liberals control this ball through
tricks or tokenism false promises of
integration and civil rights in this
game of deceiving and using the American
Negro the white liberals have complete
cooperation of the Negro civil rights
leader who sell our people out for a few
crumbs of token recognition token
games token
progress now when you hear this this
speech is given in the 60s maybe late
50s and in 60s cuz he he died I want to
say February of uh 1965 MLK died Dr King
died April 4th of 68 right so this
message is being given at a time where
it's like wait a minute were white
liberals the same then as they are today
have they been at it for this long of a
Time where even Malcolm X said this how
do you process what Malcolm X Malcolm X
just said in this message I totally
agree and it's been the foundation of
everything that I have done since then
that's what drove me I go further by
saying that many of the black elected
officials and others commit
treason treason against their own people
by using race to deflect attention away
from their own
failures in in Baltimore with Freddy
gray was killed that's when to to
deflect attention away when why are
blacks failing in school systems and in
cities run by their own people for the
past 50 years if racism were the issue
then tell me why are they
failing and but the answer that they
give is well the police are agents of
white supremacy there's always a racial
deflection that prevents them from
taking respons ibility of why they are
running their systems but but many of
them are hypocrites because they don't
live by the same rules Ellena Holmes
Norton Jesse Jackson Jun all of them
sent their children to private schools
in Washington while opposing school
choice for poor black people so you have
this contradiction but race really is
being used as a shield and a sword a
shield to deflect attention away from
their failure to address problems that
were promised by the Civil Rights
Movement how can you manipulate for this
long though one may ask you know how can
you man 2012 93% of African-Americans
voted Democrat 2016 89% of
African-Americans voted Democrat 2020
87% so to 93 89 887 voted Democrat M you
know Malcolm X said this at the year
that he said this is 60s something years
how can you manipulate an entire voting
block an entire Community for for this
many decades because race is a very
emotional deeply emotional issue it's
like the state of Israel is the Jews
it's an emotional issue like abortion is
to the to to the right to life and and
so it it is a deeply and they know it
and they do manipulate it uh that long
but also it's because Republicans have
not been competitive either when they
were they were successful look at dick
reard in in Cal in in La he was the
first Republican mayor in 35 years how
did he do that dick Reon planted
charitably two years before he Harvest
politically he went to the lowincome
Hispanic community and said what is it
that you need to rebuild your community
and he brought some of his friends to
the table and they built a
state-of-the-art facility so so that
those communities could engage in after
school activities to teach English it
was only after he planted charitably
that those liberal Democratic leaders
embraced dick rer and he became the
first Republican mayor in 35 years and
when he got reelected by 60% of the
demographic uh DeSantis in
2018 got elected because of the black
vote he would ran against uh Gillum
right Andrew Gillum Andrew Gillum
but DeSantis only won by 32,000 votes
because 100,000 lowincome black parents
voted because of his position on choice
and education they voted for him even
though Barack Obama and Oprah Winfrey
was brought into campaign for Gillum so
you have a 100,000 blacks voting against
Obama and voting against Oprah to elect
because because they made a decision
based upon the content of the issue and
not enough
Republicans are did what the stist did
and and when they do I think they will
be competitive but apathy is what's
keeping blacks of also if you look in
some of those high crime neighborhoods
in the mayor's race only 8 to 10% of the
people vote because there's just such
deep apathy in those communities but
low-income blacks are asleeping Giants
they're going to wake up one day soon
low-income blacks are going to wake up
one day wake up and realize how they're
being pimped and how they're being used
the what's the Tipping Point what he
steing for them to wake up it's been
years the the violence that is is you
seeing now a lot of unrest 80% of black
Americans poll do not support Defender
police MH 80% but you won know that by
looking at the
media you know that and and so and 6 %
of blacks do not believe that racial
discrimination is the biggest barrier to
their
flourishing and so the challenge that we
have is to and what we're doing at the
Woodson Center is giving voice to those
to to those people we have about um a
couple thousand women uh who are voices
of black mothers United these are women
moms who lost children to urban violence
they're coming the leading cause of
death for black kids is homicide in
Silicon Valley is suicide with among
teenagers and in Appalachia is
prescription
drugs well the Woodson Center brought
together representatives from those
three communities we call it the
mother's
Consortium and and we and it was just
common ground there we were United and
so what we must do is we must
deracialized race but it's not enough to
talk about what you're against you got
to talk about what you're for we should
be for the saving of our children's
lives and so what we're doing at the
wton center is mobilizing mothers from
those three communities to come together
and and say that we must do everything
we can to fill the whole that's in the
hearts of our children that causes them
to devalue their life to the point where
they're willing to take their own or
take someone else's it's different sides
of the same coin so did did you find out
what the reasoning was for homicide for
suicide and for prescription drugs like
what's the reason emptiness EMP
emptiness when you keep telling when the
also when you keep broadcasting to
people that they live in a country that
despises them particularly with
low-income blacks that you live in a
country that despises you like the 1619
project said that racism defines all
whites or villains and and and
victimizers and they're privileged that
message gets communicated to blacks that
perhaps the reason that this is
happening is because they are
unworthy so the so the message of
unworthiness comes from the very people
who are supposed to be social justice
Warriors and and you say to a child in a
white child that you you're you're
devalued because you're privileged and
and you are an oppressor that kind those
are really dangerous messages that we're
sending to our children when we keep
saying to them that they live in a
country that despises them because
they're white and and and and derides
them because they're black I mean that's
a that's a very poisonous message and
that's why at the Woodson Center we're
doing everything we can to mobilize that
consensus among the people suffering the
problem go ahead Tom sir did did you
ever um uh come to be acquainted with
the Reverend Eevee Hill I know Eevee
Hill very well yeah and what he did in
downtown Los Angeles Church of the open
door MH was very interesting and I'm
sure you know this but I'll say it for
the audience Reverend Eevee Hill pointed
out that every young man regardless of
race needs love discipline and respect
starting at age 11 to 18 for them to
mature as young boys to Here Come the
hormones and to truly mature into young
men and he warned that in his analysis
of the terrible what was going on in his
backyard and for people don't know Eevee
Hill churchy open door it's down there
just blocks away from USC this great
pillar of learning and South Central Los
Angeles which has got all the
reputations with the Crips and bloods
went on and he pointed out that the
gangs perfectly fill the hole that a
fatherless um home does with love
discipline and respect cuz in the gang I
will love you and kill for you and I
will defend you with my own own life
discipline you will not break our laws
or rules or you will be killed and then
respect comes from negative
accomplishments here you go you got to
cap one of the other gang members today
so that we can show that you're a man
and you're part of us and love
discipline and respect is needed by
young men 11 to 18 and the gangs
perfectly filled the hole and it's what
you're talking about the hole in the
heart and what the Woodson Center is
doing it almost sounds like the um
sermon I heard that there's a God shaped
hole in the heart of every man every
person and that you're trying to fill
that and and we have people who we have
models around the country of young men
and women who have stepped up in our
being and we can measure we can tell you
680 kids from one public housing project
one of the worst in the country went on
to college we have a an institution
pineywood Day School uh it's a boarding
school that was started 115 years ago in
in Jackson Mississippi they pull from
the same demographic as a Baltimore
School 96% of the kids come there go on
to college or post-secondary education
when they're from the same demographic
as the ones who are failing in the in
the public school system so we have
models of moral and spiritual Excellence
that builds on the same values the
challenge is how do we resource them and
and take them and and make them the the
center piece for instance the the whole
song Rich Man north of Richmond by
Oliver Anthony 50 uh uh million people
responded most of them black to his
message when you go go on internet you
will see that a lot of the black DJs to
speak to that population in the black
community resonated with his
message yes he's very popular why do you
think because I think there is a quest a
deep thirst for virtue there's a deep
thirst to return to the values that
sustained us from the beginning but we
we don't have a vehicle for that for
that desire to get expressed and that's
what we're trying to do at the Woodson
Center is to say to people uh the the
millions the the the guilty white people
who put a 100 million into to to Black
lives matters and then put 50 million
into this Center at Boston University
Abraham Ki uh studying anti-ra racism
how could they raise $50
million in in in a year to study racism
and and guilty white corporations give a
100 million to Black lives matter this
and both of those institutions are
frauds why can't we invest that kind of
money into institutions within the
community like voices of black mothers
United like pineywood day school so what
we're trying to do to say if you get
more of what you reward and less of what
you punish so we really need the shift
of the focus of our
investments in
institutions that speak to the uh uh
founding values of the country I want to
talk to you about one of the clips that
you did where you talked about BLM a
couple years
ago uh got uh a lot of eyeballs and I
want to read this article to you from
BLM finances Under Fire on only 33% of
donations given to Charities as execs
paid millions of dollars this is an
article that came out just a couple
months ago uh black lives matter matter
finances are under scrutiny once again
as tax documents show the nonprofit is
on the brink of bankruptcy the
organization ended last year in red
while doing out uh do doing out Millions
to those close to beam Founders F
following the murder of George Floyd in
2020 supporters donated a staggering $90
million to Black lives matter this
nonprofit ended the fiscal year with $9
million and deficit okay how do you do
that I don't know the federal filings
from 2020 to 2022 shows just a third $30
million of the 90 million went to other
charitable organizations with $22
million going to expenses this in
includes a 1.6 million 1.6 million that
went into the father of BLM co-founder
Patrice cullers for Security Services
another 2.1 million to BLM uh board
member shaloma Bowers for Consulting so
this thing had so much momentum that you
couldn't watch a ba a basketball game
without BLM being all over the place on
the floor you couldn't watch a football
game you couldn't watch anything without
this being everywhere and God forbid if
somebody said all lives matter instead
of black lives matter they would get uh
ousted they would get how dare you say
such a thing like that that you know all
lives matter one why do you think got so
much moment and two you know now that
everybody realizes it was a fraud are
these people going to be held
accountable what do you think should
happen no they won't they won't be held
accountable but again I must say that
progressives have a ground game George
sorus knows he know which he want to do
with Ferguson is rent a
rioter 51 of the people arrested for
rioting in Ferguson only one was from
Ferguson Soros and other people know
that you got to have a ground game you
you you got to have a George
Floyd uh and and once you have that they
they they they they
invest and I'm saying those of us who
believe in the in in the foundational
principles of the country we must
encourage people then to invest in
organizations and and institutions Civic
institutions that extol the who who
extol the virtues of the country you
know like the pineywood school that
school should should not be struggling
for money it should be well-funded the
same people who are writing checks to
them should be looking for opportunities
to write checks to organizations who who
are uh who support the values that they
say they believe in but they don't do it
they'll spend aund million for political
campaigns and the amount of money that
we invest in something confers
validation on it the amount of money we
spend on something confirms the
validation on confirm confirms
validation just as the left believe that
America is racist and therefore the
George Floyds of this world symbolizes
that we need to have symbols on our side
like the pineywood school like these
other organizations that that the
Woodson Center voices of black mothers
united we must get people to invest in
organizations that reflect the values of
the nation
uh as much as the other side invest but
it has to do with where we
invest by the way if if you were to put
a name on it or organization on it uh
specifically more name and a face who
has used and abused the black vote and
the black community the most over the
you know past few decades I think the
Congressional Black
Caucus they they stay in power it's they
run like almost banana republics they
get elected to office and and they stay
uh they have $60 million gets invested
by corporations and it buys their
silence and and and they're they're
allowing themselves to be used um you
know as Pawns in other words uh someone
said that whites in slavery looked at
blacks as as
property and um black elect officials
look at low-income blacks as
pawns who else who else uh I think all
of the the the the the so-called civil
rights organizations uh the Urban League
NAACP uh all those organizations that
that fought so-called for for freedom
and they have morphed into a race
grievance industry and and they're being
led by their nose by other
groups and and allowing the rich
tradition of the Civil Rights Movement
to be
appropriated for other groups in society
so maybe this is a question for me
coming from a a 45y old okay I can
officially say I'm 45 now okay 45y old
um so you hear the story you watch the
documentaries you watch the movies you
read the books here's how it was in
1920s 30s 40s 50s 60s I wasn't there
during that time to know it I came to
the States in 1990 November 20th when I
was in Iran and Germany
so for for someone that's been around
like yourself 1937 until today and
you've been watching what's been
happening is this the most divided we've
been is this the most divisive we've
been is this you know the darkest we've
been or has it been like this and it's
always been a fight you know again
you're you've seen it from your own eyes
what what have you noticed happened over
the past few decades what's been
happening over the past few decades is
there are people who are genuinely
interested in destroying this country
why would they though and who are these
people I have no idea why any body the
the very fact that that Europe uh like
France and Germany and England and the
United States are as the destination for
for people from all over the world
they're trying to get here why are they
they risking their lives to get here if
what's here is not uh uh useful and and
and helpful so I really think you got
the cynics who are really who for
whatever reason that I don't know who
want to destroy this country but then I
think a a vast majority of people who
are well-intended but ill informed and
they are the ones that we at the Woodson
Center are trying to migrate by our by
our examples to say to them that the
virtues of the nation that that have uh
stood the test of time are also
applicable to today and we are seeing
more and more people being recruited uh
from this thinking and being supportive
so you cannot assume that everybody
who's in opposition to this is doing so
because they're ill-willed you must
distinguish between those who are ill
intended and those who are ill will and
there are some people who are ill will
who who really want to see Socialism or
even communism come back let's just be
very Frank about that and and but but
they are using America's birth defect of
slavery uh as has a means to demean the
country and only black America can
withdraw that moral Authority yeah
because what what I see right now is
everything is you know men against women
right right you know like the whole I
got a book that's coming out on December
5th choose your enemies wisely and I'm
going to do the audiobook every time I'm
doing the audio I'm reading the book for
like 100 times because I've written the
book but I'm we're doing the audiobook
today as well and as I'm reading this
thing choose your enemies wisely and
you're seeing what's going on okay men
versus women okay the enemy of every
woman should be men because men are
taking something away from you right
it's Christians versus Muslims
Republicans versus Democrats Republicans
are the enemy right it's blacks versus
white church scores versus non-church
scores it's you know straight versus you
know lgbtq and we have to teach lgbtq
yet take God out of school because
that's more important we shouldn't be
imposing God on PE on kids but we should
be imposing you know sexuality amongst
kids employer versus employee being
abused and used and abused by unions
right you constantly see this division
parents against kids dividing kids
against parents you can do whatever you
want to do and you don't have to get
your dad's permission you don't have to
get your mom's permission of course you
do you have to get that permission this
desire to want to
constantly create a division there has
to be a clear outcome to it you know you
one can look at it and say okay if it's
just pure evil it's the Art of War
you're trying to divide and conquer
great but who is dividing and what do
they want to conquer you know who are
these people that want to conquer you
mentioned George Soros earlier on what
he's doing with funding of all these
protests and you know how he's figuring
out ways how to pin people against each
other I want to know from your
perspective I know you said I don't know
who it is but I kind of want to go a
little bit deeper with this again for
someone someone that was born in
1937 this division that's going on why
why would they want to do this and who
do you think would be behind wanting to
divide America the way that they're
trying to do I'm not so sure that you
have to have an answer that in order to
change it you're not so sure you have to
have the answer if you don't know the
enemy you have to know the enemy's
motives and desires don't you not
necessarily I think if you if you
mobilize enough people to conf confront
that enemy you don't know who the enemy
is so so but but you know what the enemy
does you see you see examples of it when
you see people attacking the
police we in our community we know that
there are people who are saying that we
should attack the police uh there was an
old brother uh when the clan like 20
members of the clan came to Washington
DC in a rickety old school bus and 5,000
people tried to kill him reporter went
into lowincome uh area Ward 8 in
Washington and a 75y old black man they
said are you going to join the protest
he said bring the clan down here if they
can get rid of these drug
dealers and now and and that man was
stating a reality and that is that that
the drugs and the violence in his
community is much more of a threat to
his well-being than some Talk of the
clan when you begin to mobilize people
to pursue the protection of their
interest you don't have to know why
someone else is is against you all you
have to do is mobilize the people who
are with you and for you and they will
stand against anyone trying to knock the
door down to get
in yeah I I it's I mean you can spend
your time in finding out and so what do
you do when you find out who who who
well but that's how it works during a
war when when you're dealing with war
and you're dealing with a gang you can
keep fighting against it's gang members
but then if you go and show strength
that you can take out the gang leader at
the top then everybody El scatters all
over the place but also in the second
world war for instance I always say that
that we we we understood right now
people who are who are taking that
position they don't have a ground game
they don't have a ground in other words
if a lot of conservatives if you were
fighting the second world we would only
have a navy and an Air Force okay and we
would bomb the hell out of uh Norman and
wait for Hitler to show up on the no we
understood that we've got to go in and
support partisans who are who are in
that in in and help them to defeat
inside we also know we need a n we need
a Marines we need soldiers it's hand
toand combat and our lowincome leaders
in these communities we have created
islands of Excellence where we have
stopped the violence we don't have to
know why the violence uh is is
persisting all I know is that the Young
young men that we turned around we went
from 53 murders in a five square block
area to zero for 12 years Bening terror
you're saying huh you're talking about
bending terrrace bending terrorist we so
now do I have to know why the violent no
all I know is what conditions do you
need to produce in order to change and
improve it that's that's what we need to
do and so we we've taken what worked in
Bening tariffs and extended it to
Milwaukee to Dallas you can export your
remedies without knowing in precisely in
each City why the problem exists all
you've got to do is concentrate on what
is curing the
disease it's the it's what is the how
how do we cure snake bite we take the
Venom of the snake to create the
antivenom and that's the approach that
we take in these communities we re we
know how to go and create uh peace one
one of our groups Last Summer in one of
the most violent neighborhoods for 100
days didn't have a single act of
violence we need to find out how they
did that and how can we take that and
spread it to a whole neighborhood and to
a whole city so you can push the the
antivenom you can push the
an The Cure without knowing
precisely
why yeah I think there's there's
different roles different people play
you're you're playing the ground roll uh
role game ground U you know going
meeting people talking to the kids the
30% of community successfully includes
finding out who's doing it right but
then I think long term uh someone has to
take out Hitler uh someone has to take
out you know if the drug cartel's leader
all the way at the top is El Chapo or
Pablo or whoever you got to go straight
to the Top If don't that that that
influence is going to stick around until
you until they realize oh my gosh the
person person that we all follow that
leader until that guy is eliminated
we're like we we can't we can coexist
but if they get rid of him what do we do
now but all of us have roles to play I
agree so I totally get it you play a
very important role I mean I'm very
clear I got you the mind is very
pedestrian it is it is on the ground but
it's super necessary though but and you
got to have you got to have credible
examples that your approach works right
right I want to I want to show you this
I I'm online yesterday and I'm preparing
for this year I go and uh look up two
articles one I want to see what uh ACU
says about the problem of black
Americans and then I go look up prageru
okay I'm sure you're familiar with both
organizations so let's go through the
ACLU one if you can kind of pull pull
that one up first Rob that'd be great
okay so go all the way to the top of the
article so we can kind of read what it
says so here's ACLU five truths about
black history if you want to understand
the state of race in America we need to
know our path particularly the painful
Parts okay so go down now and zoom in uh
on what it says go up go up go keep
going keep going keep going America was
founded on white supremacy I mean this
is what a a ACLU say straight up the
first slave arrived here in 1619 again
going back to the 1619 project between
1619 and 1865 Virginia passed more than
130 slave statutes to regulate the
ownership of black people a 1662 law
made all children of enslaved mothers
slaves regardless of the father's race
or status or that rape by white slave
masters couldn't create a free child a
1667 uh law codified codified that
slaves were who converted to
Christianity were still slaves a 1669
law allowed slaves to be killed for
resisting Authority right okay go lower
let's go to the next one so this article
is ACLU next one terrorism even if we
refuse to acknowledge it okay and it
explains terrorism uh on what's going on
the largest terrorist attack in Oklahoma
was not the federal building in Oklahoma
City in 1995 it was down the road in
Tulsa 1921 the greenhood neighborhood of
Tulsa Oklahoma was unique in the early
20th century was referred to to Black
Wall Street and was home to Black and
Native Americans who had become wealthy
from old dis discoveries and then it
goes to saying white residents were
distributed disturbed by the grown black
wealth and sought to impose official
segregation measures in 2014 also passed
a law that forbade anyone from living a
on a block where more than three4 of the
pre-existent residents were from another
race okay so let's go a little bit if
somebody wants to read more we'll put
the link below next so keep going keep
going keep going um then we have a war
for was fought for slavery by 1860
America had 4 million slaves worth a
total of $3 billion of today's
currencies okay let's go to the next one
go to the next one go to the next one
Francis Scott Key was an avowed white
supremacist keep going to the next one
uh which is the last one reparations for
slavery have already been paid okay uh
on April 16 1862 more than eight months
before he issued the Emancipation
Proclamation Abraham lincol signed a
bill ending slavery in the District of
Columbia provided for immediate
emancipation of slaves and compensation
to slave owners loyal to the union of up
to $300 for each free slave over the
next n9ine months the broad the Board of
Commissioners appointed to administer
the ACT approved petitions completely or
in part for former owners of Freedom
2989 former slaves Lincoln
Administration paid about a million doll
of slave owners in DC for the loss of
property if you don't know some of these
facts before reading them here what else
don't you know about the Hidden Truths
of black American American history okay
so that's a clu now let's go to Prager
here's what Prager you says the top five
issues facing black Americans number
five victim mentality okay um not
holding someone back from more than
seeing himself as a victim why because a
victim is not responsible for a
situation everything is someone else's
fault and a victim sees little chance of
improving his life how he how can he get
ahead if there's someone holding him
back all this makes him victim all all
this makes the victim unhappy frustrated
and angry and then in the bottom it a so
victim so much victim status primary I
can I call it victimology unfortunately
many black churches preach the
victimology many black parents pass it
on to their children inner city schools
teach it to their students and the black
media reinforces it meanwhile the NAACP
and other black grievance groups
fundraise it number four lack of
diversity blacks repeatedly demand an
honest Dialogue on debate about race but
how can there be an honest dialogue
about race between blacks and whites
when there is virtually no honest
dialogue between blacks and blacks it's
hypocritical and if a black does does
think whites are ultimately responsible
for Black people's problems they're
labeled a sellout and Uncle Tom a race
Trader I'm sure you've experienced some
of that yourself over the years as long
as this type of group thing exists race
reverence of the Al Sharpton Jesse
Jackson types will continue to be
celebrated while independent black
thinkers such as Professor Thomas Soul
Walter Williams and yourself will be
shunned okay let's go to number three
Urban
terrorism as just about everyone knows
what few talk about publicly in major
black cities violent black on black
crimes is a is rampant a Department of
Justice study from 1980 to 2008 revealed
that blacks accounted for almost half of
the nation's homicide victims
47.4% and more than half of offenders
52.4 all while only
133% uh uh of Americans population okay
so that's another study we can go to go
to the next one now number two
proliferation of baby mamas the
disintegration of the nuclear family
which you talked about briefly earlier
according to uh moan report he was a
Senator I believe right Tom how do you
say his last name Daniel Patrick Monahan
yeah Monahan in 1965 nearly 25% of black
children will were born to unwet mothers
the report author Daniel Patrick said
that this was a disaster in the making
he of course vilified by so-called black
leaders and and their Progressive allies
but he was right today out of wedlock
birth rates is nearly
75% 1965 I think you talked about this
earlier 25% to today 75% last but not
least is the unquestioning allegiance to
socalled Progressive policies okay
unwavering loyalty to Progressive
liberal policies is the primary reason
why these dire conditions exist it both
makes them possible and perpetuates them
it's no coincidence that progressmonitor
were single parent homes failing schools
rampant poverty and uh crime uh
predominant I can keep reading this and
talking about what's going on in the
trule the point I want to make is two
very different views of the problem
we're facing in America one is you know
white supremacist here's what happened
even this even that the other one is
responsibility do something about it but
here's the problem how do we get these
two groups to either come together and
if we can't how do you get the people
that are in the middle open-minded to
say trust me this mindset on this side
it's going to give you a better life
than this mindset on this side want to
be a victim again I think that the the
response to Oliver Anthony's Song uh
gives you a hint at that there is a
thirst a deep thirst for
virtue uh the very fact that a homeless
man in Boston uh a couple years back uh
found a napsack with
$43,000 it and turned it in and with
there was a GoFundMe and within 3 days
they raised $93,000 from him that meant
deepen in and that happened four times
uh a black man in O Oakland who was
homeless 53 years old a woman emptied
her change person her $115,000 diamond
wedding bracelet was there when she went
back five hours later he said you're
looking for this they had a fundraiser
for him
$100,000 that's says to me that deep in
the in in is a desire to support virtue
like that and and so what we do was is
that the way you undermine the moral
authority of the ACLU and these other
group is to equip the people suffering
the problem to speak for themselves and
they speak for themselves the way um the
the black mothers United have come
together for example you support groups
so that now we've got 20 chapters about
2,000 of these moms who are having um uh
positive interactions we were honoring
the police and organizing uh events with
students are being mobilized by the
thousands who speak out against violence
in other words you've got to invest in
the institutions within those
communities where people are speaking up
for themselves uh and make them the new
hero
but again it's going to take in
Investments but but conservatives don't
don't invest the way uh the way they do
they'll invest in think tanks because
their children can go there and be
interns and and we you know we seem to
think all you got to do is publish the
right
policies uh and then people will change
it it's not a rhetorical battle that
we're in this is a this is a battle for
meaning this is a b of substance we must
demonstrate to the American public that
the values of this nation have the
consequence of improving the quality of
life and and no and if people can find
content and meaning in their life in a
drug infested crime ritten neighborhood
and we highlight that and celebrate it
and make them the new
Heroes then they are the ones that we
can stand shoulder-to-shoulder with and
say we must uh we must push back but
again it takes investment yeah you know
it's it's interesting you say this I I
look at uh um I run multiple
companies and when when you run multiple
companies then you have multiple se-
sues then you have multiple department
managers general managers people that
are running leaders and one group will
have five employees reporting to them
with 10 on the team one will have 20 one
will have 30 one we have eight and I'll
go to one Department I'm like wow
everybody here so
enthusiastic they come to work so
excited right they want to say hey let's
show to the company that we are the best
department right we're excited to get
stuff done and then you go to one
department and I'll talk to One employee
another employee another employee they
all like well how's your well you know
we're trying to I've had better days and
you know we're going to see what's going
to happen and I'm like why is everybody
talk like they're miserable you know and
so like unhappy and victims and then you
go and talk talk to the leader at the
top well you know no one ever gives us
credit and no one ever does this I'm
like got it so then you go and you look
at two coaches and as a father I got
four kids uh my my um youngest son he's
had a lot of different baseball coaches
okay and he's currently with a coach
that he loves he really likes working
for this guy but this guy busts his butt
like I remember one time uh he said
something the coach comes in he says hey
he comes talk me he uh Pat I just w't
tell you he's going to be running the
entire practice today I'm like do your
thing I said but tell me why because he
did this I said n totally get it go for
it I got your back so what does the
coach do he puts him to work running
running running running I mean it's hot
outside running running running running
running but you know what we're going to
go back to that coach because he
produces winners he produces toughness
he produces a teamwork mentality he
produces the level of humility he
produces the Love of the Game it's
exciting to want to play for this guy we
had another coach was like you don't
know what you're
doing everything was just constantly
like negative this this that and he just
kids didn't want to play for him so for
me both sides can say whatever they want
to say but at the end of the day there's
only one way we judge which philosophy
is a better philosophy and it's based on
the fruits it Bears period based on what
you produce if you produce good citizens
that do great things you're doing some
right Tom's got two girls one of them
got a 1560 on her sat out of 1600 okay
she gets to go to whatever school she
wants to go to she's got a 4.6 GPA at
one of the best schools in the state of
Florida with I think the best math
program in this in the entire State of
Florida and she's very very smart so is
their youngest daughter guess what the
parents are doing something right the
philosophies they're teaching us
something right so for me scream off the
top of your lungs say whatever you want
to say if one philosophy is producing
leaders the other one is not I want to
know what the philosophy of the people
that are producing leaders you know
right now with the whole Israel
Palestine challenges taking place I want
to ask you a question here Jews small
community 15 million of them
right a man named Adolf Hitler tried to
eliminate all of them that was his goal
he wanted to get rid of him so when you
look at the charter of Hamas that says
their goal is to eliminate Israel off
the face of the Earth Shar La is the
what they want to do that's their
Charter not the 2017 one but the one
from
1988 that was kind of Hitler's Charter I
want to get rid of Jews okay he failed
but at the cost of how many lives
millions millions six million whatever
the numberers we've heard six we've
heard 20 we've heard eight let's say six
million lives right so you have Jews and
you have slavery you have the Holocaust
and you have slavery both C catastrophic
we're not sitting here to compare which
is worse than the other I'm not doing
that somebody else can go write a book
about that and compare it that is not my
specialty what I want to what I want to
study is as a person who's Armenian
Assyrian from
Iran a part of my ethnicity Community
sometimes they're victims but you don't
understand what happened to us you know
the genocide and all this other stuff
and another side is like yeah why don't
we go out there and do something and
make a name for ourselves so for the
history they can show us that we are we
are drivers we are leaders we're going
to make it work but one person's like
well that's why because of you don't
know what we went through and our in our
ancestors what we went through so why do
you think the mindset of Jews who have
risen in levels of business of Hollywood
of so many different places they made
the money they've done all these things
what what do you think is the difference
in the mindset of two different
communities I don't know if somebody
like yourself have even even studied
that or invested to see what the
difference between mindset is they' both
had a very tragic history of what
happened to them but uh on the Jew side
they stepped up and they become leaders
in many different sects why do you think
that is well Frederick dougas had to
struggle with this in his book Up From
Slavery Fredick Douglas said that the
worst time on the plantation was at
Christmas because slaves were given off
be from Christmas to New
Year's but the slave master wanted the
slaves to interpret freedom is
synonymous with
self-indulgence so he supplied free rum
to the slaves and encouraged them to
drink and he would often have
competition between which slaves could
outdrink the other slave owners
interested he said so he wanted slaves
to interpret Freedom as the
self-indulgent so that they would get so
sick that they would be happy to
surrender to slavery to man as opposed
to slav to Rome wow and some slaves
brought into that but others responded
to the same uh challenge by taking that
time to visit family members on other
plantations another one took that time
to work and earn so they can earn money
to purchase their freedom the same
exposure different
responses and I think that's what we
that we have to understand that we must
look at those who chose the more
responsible response to circumstance and
you're never defined by your external
circumstance so we must tell the story
of those who did not succumb to the
temptation to be what the victim eyes or
wanted us to
be and but again but we but we teach
through
examples and writing the stories of
those who triumphed in the face of
slavery when I talk to Young blacks and
I tell them of stories of people who
were born slaves who died
millionaires some of them went back and
purchased a plantation on which they
were slaves and took in the destitute
family of the slave master what a story
Robert
Smalls he was born in Sumpter South
Carolina and he was on a slave on a on a
warship and he and six members of his uh
crew
when the when the when the captain went
off for dinner to stole the ship and put
on the Master's cap and came through uh
the
various I'm sorry said formerly brought
his master's house and served as a
collector of the Customs Robert
Smalls right wow what a
story but not only that he became
wealthy and because of his um of his
heroism turning the ship over
Smalls was celebrated by Lincoln and as
a consequence he permitted blacks to
fight in the in the Civil War and but
after slavery Robert Smalls was um given
a
commission he also became a wealthy
businessman went back and purchased a
plantation on which he was a slave and
his wife the slave H his wife and
children were destitute he took them in
and allowed her to sleep in her same bed
because she didn't realize slavery was
over wow to me this is an act of radical
Grace and there are other stories of
biddy Mason a woman who was born in
1818 and uh walked a thousand miles
behind a wagon with three children one
by the slave master and then she later
went to walk behind the wagon to um uh
California where she was freed by the
court
and she was a midwife and saved money uh
to uh buy property and she died one of
the wealthiest women in Los Angeles
she's a founder of the church out there
wow illiterate three children and became
a wealthy philanthropist unbelievable
and and Elijah Elijah McCoy you don't
know that story born of uh Fugitive
Slave parents
was trained in in in Canada and came
back uh to become he an engineer an
inventor but he was given the worst job
at the at the railroads in Chicago
Elijah McCoy and Elijah
McCoy uh in was given a job of of
physically uh oiling The Wheels on the
trains
right and it was dangerous he invented
the machine that would automatically uh
lubricate the machine and changing the
whole industry so they could then travel
faster he and and that's why people
tried to develop knockoffs and they said
uh no we want The Real
McCoy so that's where that expression
The Real McCoy came from because they
wanted his he had 17 inventions he was
in the inventur Hall of Fame and so I
can go on and on about people like that
these are the kind of stories that we
tell our young people if a 100 if you
ask a 100 kids right now ages 6 to 15
about these three names how many of them
would know none of them that's why what
the Woodson Center done with this this
curriculum we've developed 30 case
studies like this around the country and
as part of our they've been downloaded
117,000 times over the past year so
again in every state in the Union
they're being reviewed who's writing
books about these guys we are you are
you know you know how HQ penguin has
these books for kids that they write and
we have like 600 of these at our house
our kids have read I've never heard any
of these books stories of them being
written by HQ we're trying to get uh
children's books written from the but
again we need to invest in these kinds
of things this is my point I say to
conservatives and said if you get more
of what you reward unless it what but
why aren't we if if you say you're for
American values if you for these
principles then why not invest in them
damn it don't whine about what the other
side is doing invest in the things you
believe in I agree the left does it
exactly and what's happening in our
books you know we get worried about oh
they're revising history because they're
going to make this man and this woman
seem more racist revising history what
we also have to keep in mind is there
suppressing history this does not go
with the narrative so they're not going
to talk about Elijah McCoy that says do
you know that everybody's been saying
The Real McCoy man that thing is The
Real McCoy and it's always a compliment
to Quality you know whether you're
tasting chili or you see some some
product you said man that thing's a Real
McCoy that works that was worth my
dollar you people don't even know you're
talking about a phrase that went with
Elijah McCoy who found a way for the
safety of railroad workers to lubricate
trains so they could go faster and to be
less risk to the working guy that was
responsible for that every time you say
that you're really talking about Elijah
McCoy you don't even know it so what's
happening in these history books it's
not just they're changing facts it's
they're not letting certain facts and
narratives and biogra biographies be a
part of it because it's because it
messes with the narrative right the
whole issue of refrigerated trucks they
invented by a black man The Real McCoy
wow go go Ahad I'm loving these St Tru
but in our in our Publications we we
have we have a lot of examples all of
these are the Woodson Center you can go
let's make sure we put these links as
well yeah you can study the story in
fact we're trying to do animations on
some of these again I love that this is
where we need the investment I love that
we do not have the investment I love
that so you can you can imagine how many
people black white how many donate how
many people donated to your organization
last 12 months uh probably about 8,000
8,000 people well but we need to really
I can tell you right now right after
this I'm going to give you a $10,000
donation so whenever we're done with
this I'm telling you right now sanil if
you're listening to this immediately
afterwards let's get the information
let's send $10,000 to this organization
I love these stories they inspire me I
love it I love I love I would love to
have more people hear the hear these
stories and read about these types of
stories I'm only scratching the surface
I can I can sit here all day and tell
you uh uh the stories of a woman uh Her
Name Escapes you right now but she
walked behind a wagon uh from the south
to Denver and worked in the mines she
opened a laundry there to wash the long
johns of miners right and she collected
the the the the gold dust from the
draining it up and she used that to be
Capital she became one of the wealthiest
women the wealthiest women in Colorado
she ended up investing through a uh with
a white partner and she now is was
started and became one of the the
wealthiest property owners in Colorado
not just black but anyone so our young
people need to be told this is the
American story it is not America slav
was our birth defect none of us should
be defined by the worst of what we used
to
be I say this all the time when I'm
speaking how many you want to be defined
by the worst you ever ever were no as in
America should not be defined by its
birth defect this is what we were but
this is what we we we we have the will
to become yeah that's the tool you just
struck something there that is the tool
of narrative if people are paying
attention the tool of narrative is to
never let you get away something in your
past yet we want and people who are
paying attention we want to see reation
rates drop and celebrate the man and
woman that comes out of prison and
becomes something different and we we
say they're not what they were and we
celebrate it move it forward but if
you're running a narrative you need to
keep people chained to the birth defect
of History that's right and a and a
birth def is a birth def it is but we
don't Define ourselves uh uh by that I
mean there's so many uh uh in important
stories uh some some of the the the
people who were born slave became not
just the wealthiest black but the
wealthiest
person uh in in that situation they own
property uh we had U golf clubs we had
Resorts and by the way today we have
some of the best stories of
African-Americans that made it to the
top so many of them that have had
different difficult lives and they made
it all the way to the top but we don't
tend to focus on those stories you know
we
we want to talk about what the white man
did we want to talk about how the
boogeyman is the white man the boogeyman
is you know uh Republicans the boogeyman
is this and and somehow some way I don't
think that's working anymore because
even a lot of people who were part of
that mindset are sitting around saying I
I don't know if I fully agree with what
you're doing I don't know if these guys
are really for us I don't know if
they're really supporting us Tom what
was the story about Coca-Cola and and uh
project rainbow I don't know if you want
to uncap that no this was uh Jesse
Jackson that there was a book written
about Jesse Jackson rainbow push
Shakedown and for all of the things that
Jesse Jackson was involved in American
Civil Rights rainbow rainbow push and
correct me if you know a different
history lost its way and it it it was
fueling Jesse Jackson rather than
fueling change well he would go to uh
companies and demand a consulting fee to
bring diversity to management well he
went to LA Coke which was the largest
bottler of Coca-Cola in the United
States their bottlers were regionally
and were owned regionally and he went in
there and told the president who has now
passed away but I had a personal
relationship with him and I I knew this
man he said he came in and said well we
need this much money for um diversity
training an adversity program that
you're going to pay rainbow push and he
said and then you know we'll we'll do a
press release and do the stuff together
and he said and they they played along
with it and they said come back in a
week comes back a week later and he says
okay here's what we're doing remember
this is Riverside outside of Los Angeles
okay the following people including this
large number of Hispanics management are
going to be laid off so we can achieve
your diversity goals and we want you to
be right there at the pulpit with us at
the podium with us when we make this
press release about what we're going to
do and how we're going to change this
and Jesse Jackson says he stopped and he
said no I I I don't think this is
necessary I don't think that we need to
do this CU they called this Bluff
because they were already highly diverse
in that area because of the tremendous
Hispanic population and Asian population
it was Riverside and it was already just
because they were hiring from the local
community they had the face and the
ethnic mix of the local community and
Jesse Jackson thought he was knocking on
the door of Coca-Cola not a locally
owned business that was already fairly
diverse for its time and they called
this Bluff on it they say yeah come on
up come on up to the podium and let's
announce all these people are getting
laid off to do it your way uh no I I
think we're good
here I love that well the story I
remember about Jesse and and I was in
the movement with all of them was that
every Saturday they would have a call
because they were boycotting anhis of
bush um for lack of management whatnot
and every it would be reporting every
Saturday all of a sudden Saturday the
call stopped he never announced never
canceled it his son got the the
franchise in Chicago he has it to the
day so when his son got the bun the the
distributorship in Chicago the protest
went away get out of here no K can you
search that are you check it there's a
book that was written who wrote the book
uh Shakedown Robert have you read the
book yeah unfor wow two of Jackson's
sons yoseph and Jonathan were granted a
lucrative anheiser Bush distribution
distributorship in Chicago in 1998 this
franchise gives the younger Jackson
exclusive rights to sell 30 to $40
million worth of Budweiser and other
products in an area that includes
Wrigley
[Music]
Field I mean there endless examples oh
my gosh there's endless examples of this
kind of Shakedown that's why I say that
people like that engage in moral treason
because it's using the condition of your
people as the bait and the switch comes
when the resources show up and you use
it to to to do
that I mean even they even wrote a book
about it Rob you just found this here
Shakedown exposing the real the Jesse
Jackson this was written in 2003 uh five
years after he did that I think it was a
98 or 99 and he became a New York Times
bestseller Shakedown Jesse Jackson does
Jesse Jackson still carry the name the
weight that he did 20 30 40 years ago I
don't think he has for the last 20 years
for the last 20 years again but he's
more more darling of the liberal uh
White press than he is the black
community you don't see him in in
communities it's like you don't see
Sharpton and Ferguson or any of these
other communities
either a question for you the concept of
racism when I was in the army man we all
got along it didn't matter what it was I
mean I'm in South Carolina and uh you
know whites blacks they they would say
I've never met an Iranian before you
know you're the first Iranian I've ever
met I've never met a nose like that
before we don't have noses like that in
America right they would say things like
this and I'd go to Alabama and we're at
a waffle house and this this uh waiter
uh waitress pulls up waiter pulls up and
is looking on my nose like where are you
from I said I'm from Iran he said you
from Iran I said yeah he says what are
you do in America I said I'm in your
army H1 Airborne I'm in the US Army he
says what are you doing in the US Army I
said can I be honest with you can I
trust he says yes I said I'm a spy I'm
taking I'm taking everything back to
Iran are you serious no man I'm just in
the Army what are you talking about but
it was so so easy to play with these
guys and mess around with them we all
got along you were white you're black
you're this you're that we didn't
experience any racism while while I was
in the Army and today you'll hear saying
well there's more you know racism from
uh whites to blacks you know and that's
what's going on and but some will also
say there's more racism going on from
blacks towards whites you know there's
some racism going on there with a level
of hate for whites well you look at the
hate crimes yeah the majority hate
crimes are blacks against Asians and
others but you see but these are
unpleasant truths we can't talk about
that whenever I hear in Oakland
California that there's been an assault
on an Asian person and you don't hear
the race of the
victimizer you know it's black m because
60 to 70% of the assaults on Asians have
been done by blacks but we can't tell
the truth on so they just don't mention
it and but and and you see what when let
me just make this a very important Point
whenever you generalize about a group
and then try to apply remedies it always
helps those at the economic top at the
expense of those at the bottom just like
the me too movement generalizes about
women it was started by a young young
black woman in Harlem who was wanted to
have women come together and talk about
abuse it was captured by middle class
and upper income
women and became the me
movement um and as a consequence it
became uh uh people caught on the uh on
on the casting
couch but reality is that that fox did a
two-hour documentary on sexual assault
of women in prisons for two hours every
one of the victims was black every one
of the victimizers was black it never
generated a single
discussion because it did not fit the
racial narrative you let one white guard
assault a single black woman and then it
becomes national news but as a
consequence of of thus uh
uh the lowincome women in those prisons
be in other words when evil wears a
black face it does not get challenged
and so people are really injured in
that and that but that's where it
started but then it became har Harry W
uh Weinstein on the casting couch and
then so what are the remedies they offer
women should be on Boards of directors
more lawyers should be fire this only
helps educated women it doesn't help
those black women in prisons that are
being abused by black black guards and
we don't even discuss it it's not a
subject of
outrage there there's no protest about
that and this is what I mean that if you
constantly look at life through the
prism of race when black where when evil
wears a blackface it escapes detection
and and addressing and people are more
injured by by that well let me are you
are you for history you like making
history you for making history so I got
a question for you so what do you think
about the uh uh
possibilities if our current uh
president most popular presid of all
time what if he uh ends up deciding to
step down and we experience making
history the first female black president
in America Camala Harris uh how ecstatic
would you be about that Monumental
moment if that were to happen I would be
disappointed really
why why would you be disappointed
because she's a
disaster she is she doesn't she she this
would be the worst thing that could
happen to this country why is that
because she's not competent she's just
how how does she make make it to the top
how did she make it to being a VP some
would say she worked very hard to get to
where she's at right now she worked at
being black right and that's what got
her elevated no I just that that shows
you the worst of what what what race
grievance looks like that he and and any
time Nome the governor of California
says I'm going to appoint a black woman
what is that what do what do you mean
you're going to appoint a black woman
you're not saying I'm going to appoint
the most competent
person and and to me it shows you how
how degraded the whole issue of race has
become in America it's become it's
become worse than than than it's ever
been I think so you wouldn't be ecstatic
about Kamala no I would not be well Pat
and I both came from California and
people that lived in California will
tell you that when she was attorney
general um how she abused the three
strikes law and the three strikes law um
along with the um determination that if
you had 2 ounces of marijuana or some
level they would say intent to
distribute because of the
quantity and to be tough on crime you
take everybody even minor possessions
you put them in prison and she was very
good at that
and she used to speak that uh very
loudly and those of us who are in
California know that that that three
strikes laws may have been well-
intended one level but what it did was
it
disproportionately not just in jail 14
days jail at County disproportionately
imprisoned um black men in California
and it perpetuated and by the way when
they went to prison unfortunately what
goes on there is kind of like crime
college and then they come out they're
not employable so what do they turn to
other criminal Enterprises because it's
where it goes but we all see her as
incredibly disingenuous right about what
she what she did oh you you call
yourself a progressive but you also
wanted to appear tough on crime and
she'll claim that well we did this or
that and these little programs but the
programs that she would announce were
tokenism you know we're going to give um
gym membership cards once they get out
of uh prison well they've been lifting
weights for 5 years in prison why you
need you know and it was it was tokenism
and it was pandering and it was dancing
on both sides of the political line
depending on who she was speaking to for
the purpose of electability but the real
victim in all this were these citizens
who maybe made a mistake maybe were in
possession but certainly wasn't
distribution and but they used the three
strikes law for electability and had a
devastating impact on the populace yeah
I just think as again as a veteran of
the Civil Rights Movement
nothing is more disheartening than this
whole notion that that social justice
today has been defined that for blacks
that you must dumb down standards to
moments black walks into the
door that that I gave examples in our
books about the golden
13 where we pursued Excellence we didn't
ask Jackie Robinson didn't ask well
because blacks of denied access to
baseball that four strikes on you out if
you're black Jim Brown and other other
football players didn't say Well since
blacks were denied access to the NFL
that blacks only have to run eight yards
to get a first down can you
imagine you know we we didn't we didn't
ask no we we met we' met the standards
in fact I you know but one thing that I
think I'm going to do and I and I've
taken this task on is that if we can
just get rid of white guilt I think the
whole country can can take a side relief
and get improved that's why I have
become a u a a a self-certified racial
Exorcist Exorcist racial Exorcist sir
racial Exorcist So I absolve you from
the sins of slavery and Jim Crow wow I
think I'm thinking about charging maybe
$50 for a certificate so I can get a
little yeah for I want to get in on the
race hustle
too who knows maybe anheiser Bush gives
you a spot where you maybe so you know
mean it's 30 to 40 million years it's a
nice situation to be in Bob Woodson can
I got a I'm I can't be guilty race Bob
gave me an Absolution from
it hey Brendon Whitworth if you're
listening put this guy on a can yeah
um final thoughts here are you following
any I mean are you following it closely
what's going on with Israel and
Palestine yes what how can how can we
not do that what what are your thoughts
on what's going on I mean obviously at
this point activating 2,000 400 people
killed at a hospital one side saying is
the other the other sign is you
President Biden going to Israel spending
time with Netanyahu gives the message
what he says to him he says well we're
finding report that's telling us it was
them it wasn't you and we'll still keep
looking into it and then from there
Egypt still not taking anybody that's
coming across from Gaza you know the
folks who are supporting uh uh people
from Hamas or Palestine or so well the
reason why Egypt is not accepting them
is because they don't want they know if
they leave Israel is going to take over
Gaza and that's why they don't want them
to leave they want them to stay there's
no water there's no electricity there's
no hospital supplies there's no food
since last Monday that this is going on
in Gaza Strip it's pretty much a
lockdown of 2.2 million people the most
dense densely populated place in the
world where 75,000 people live within a
mile radius in the Gaza Strip and uh now
Iran's come out and saying you've
crossed the line hezbollah's kind of a
uh a Whispering saying we're ready
whenever you tell us we're ready and if
people think Hamas is Big Hamas is only
40,000 members Isis only has 8 to 16,000
but Hezbollah has
150,000 compared to Israel's 400,000 so
if Hezbollah decided to get involved
anything is possible when they get
involved right uh um what what what do
you think about what's going on right
now with the entire situation well you
know let me preface it by saying God
bless those who got nothing to say and
got the good sense not to say it uh this
is really out of my wheelhouse and
beyond my knowledge but I do know as a
lay person watching the slaughter of
babies and the rape of women by innocent
people I don't know how anybody could in
any way
support the the actions of anybody for
whatever political ideological reasons
just this act of barbarity should to me
forever defines what this group is all
about and why they must be resist Ed um
and so uh that's about that's about it I
just all I know is that I can't believe
this this this image of this Soldier
grabbing this woman by the hair and
snatching her after she's been raped and
pulling into the car that just haunts me
to think that human beings would do that
could resort to something like this man
Tom what what's the what's the latest
your hearing you know because I I see
Ray Dal was saying the chance of World
War III just went up to 50% Jamie
Diamond CEO of uh JP Morgan Chase just
said this is the most dangerous times
we've lived in decades okay in decades
um and and and we're not even thinking
about what could happen with China
Taiwan which that is an inevitable thing
that they have to be China may be doing
uh uh if all of these things is going on
at the same time Tom I mean it's do you
have any concerns your yourself as how
ugly this could get or are you pretty
optimistic about
it I'm optimistic that good men can come
together and figure this out but I'm
very concerned at the moment um I am I
am not a political Theologian but I can
look at The Dominoes here and see that
if Iran backs Hezbollah and they create
another front in the war you know China
and a little bit of Russia already are
supportive of in alliances with um Iran
and it just scares me because we we know
the last time select countries got
together as an axis and we know how bad
and devastating that was in World War II
the
escalation and I I I'm very nervous
about it and there are leaders I mean JP
Morgan has got a lot of political
Consultants that work for them because
they they were working in a global
economy and they want to understand
investment opportunities globally and
Jamie d is is being very clear without
uh singling out Iran pointing out that
we need to calm down this Gaza situation
and figure out what we're going to do
with that and if that involves Israel
with a a ground game and to pull out the
um uh the evil ones that are there and
to take care of that okay but we we
can't let this escalate to a second war
and I think everybody's worried about
destabilization of the energy market and
then dest ization of the regular Equity
markets that's what they're worried
about economically but on the back side
of it I I honestly worry about
geopolitical forces and I'm I'm as
concerned I think I've ever been in my
lifetime because I can see that one more
Domino and what's behind did you just
say you this is the most concern you've
been on your life are you really saying
that and you fully mean that no I I I
fully mean that I remember how I felt
look I remember how I felt when Reagan
was elected I remember how I felt about
global communism I remember feeling a
sense of relief when the Berlin Wall
came down and I saw citizens celebrating
I felt a sense of relief yeah because
remember at that time whether it was
part propaganda or not we were worried
about this escalation of nuclear
capability on both sides and we were
worried about it only took one crazy man
to press the button first remember those
days we worried about human Missile
Crisis yeah and yeah and there was two
sides that were very clearly find the U
it wasn't Russia it was the USSR before
we realized that all these Russian
provinces really wanted out of the of
the deal and later we found out they got
out as the first
opportunity but I was concerned about
about that wow we're only one crazy
person from a nuclear war I remember
thinking that in ' 84 I remember feeling
that and now I look at this this is as
concerned as I've been for two reasons
one is inside Germany and inside the
United States we know that the recent
Refugee um influx that there are Bad
actors in there I mean the um you you
you may have seen that there were four
uh that were caught just in the last
week that were on the terror watch list
only because they use facial recognition
at one at one flow Point how many others
have come through undetected so I'm
sorry for the long answer but I am
really concerned and it really worries
me and it seems as you look at it if
Hezbollah comes in then the Domino is
Iran with China behind them China is
going to be economically opportunistic
in the long game they're not going to
care about a 5-year War three-year War
they're looking at the aftermath because
they're already thinking and it's just
it's really worrisome it really honestly
worries me more so than it did when you
seem that you worried about one crazy
man pushing the button to create nuclear
war starting in the 80s but you knew
that there were two very clearly defined
forces there it was United States and
USSR do you remember those days where
that it seemed like it was very clear
communism versus Freedom the USSR versus
United State and it seemed like
everything was clear there weren't like
third and fourth and fifth dominoes that
you worried about did you feel that I
remember doing I was in graduate school
when the Cuban Missile Crisis and how
intense that felt about the blockade you
know did they want to listen to the the
generals to say bom you know
and and uh you know taking the measured
effect that Kennedy did and and then the
real sense of relief when there was a
pullback but again that you had forces
inside of Russia that were fighting for
Liberation we don't have that in the
Arab world I don't think the same
Dynamic what a great point you hear that
inside the USSR there were forces that
were fighting for their Liberation or
hoping for it even then as soon as it
came down you saw you know you back
Kazakhstan Ukraine they all ran and
where did they run West right but you
don't have that same Dynamic I don't
think in the in the Arab world today it
could be I don't know well we're going
to see what happens obviously um
unstable times in the Middle East
hopefully these guys can figure it out
um for us to go and show their face and
kind of let everybody know that uh we
stand with these guys we stand with
Israel uh whether you agree with it or
not it's it's it's a good thing to take
place for everyone to kind of realize if
they get to the next level potentially
us cannot be involved in another War
which is something a lot of people are
not for um most people are not for but I
hope these things these
tensions um decrease and it goes away uh
uh sooner rather than later because it
is the kind of a situation that can all
of a sudden spread like wildfire and get
pretty ugly anyway anyways having said
that it's been an honor having you on uh
robets make sure to put the link of the
book below folks if you've enjoyed the
podcast please go order the book and if
you do want to contribute towards what
they're doing we're going to put the
links as well below to the Woodson
Center I've already made my claim we're
going to do that right afterwards I
appreciate you for coming out this has
been an honor I learned so much from
listening to you and I always judge it
like that and I've gotten smarter from
listen to you thank you appreciate you
for coming out all right thank you so
much thank you so much take care
everybody have a great weekend bye-bye
bye-bye